[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARISSA GIUSTINA:
Quantum computing--
it's been all over
the news lately, often
accompanied by an
air of mystique
or an assortment of
fantastic promises.
But what does "quantum"
mean in the context
of computer hardware?
What distinguishes a quantum
computer from a regular one?
What does a quantum
computer look like?
How do we build it?
My name is Marissa
Giustina, and I'm
a research scientist in the
Google AI Quantum Hardware Lab.
I'd like to unpack
those questions.
And hopefully, in
about five minutes,
the term "quantum computer" will
have just a little more meaning
for you.
We're working to build devices
that we can interact with.
That is, devices we can
control and read out,
which behave reliably according
to a simple quantum model.
In other words, we're building
quantum computing hardware.
Quantum hardware can
be used as a tool
for approaching certain kinds
of computational problems.
So our ongoing efforts are
both to develop the hardware
and to develop algorithms
that leverage this hardware.
Let's start with
the first question.
What does it mean for
hardware to be quantum?
For that, we'll talk for a
moment about quantum mechanics.
A model is the physicist's
tool to make predictions
about what will
happen when we put
the universe into a
certain configuration
and poke it in a certain way.
For example, if you'd never
built a skyscraper before,
you might make a Lego version
before building it full scale.
That's a model.
Models can also be expressed
in the language of mathematics.
The most fundamental
model of nature we know
was developed in the
early 20th century
and is known as
quantum mechanics.
The word "mechanics"
refers to the mechanisms
by which things happen.
The word "quantum" refers
to discrete quantities
of energy or some other
physical quantity.
Within quantum mechanics,
energy comes in packets,
sometimes called photons.
And you cannot have
fractional packets.
So what's a quantum object?
People sometimes think of a
quantum object as being tiny
and a quantum leap
as being large.
However the word
"quantum" doesn't
dictate an object's size.
Actually, a quantum
object is one
that relates in a
well-defined way
to a single quantum of energy.
For instance, the photon I
mentioned before is a quantum
object.
A photon is a single
particle of energy.
Similarly, atoms
are quantum objects.
An electron flying
around an atomic nucleus
may be excited
into a higher orbit
only by a particular
quantum of energy.
There is no halfway
point between the lower
orbit and the upper orbit.
If the wrong energy is
provided, there simply
isn't a corresponding orbit
for the electron to land in.
In a nutshell, a quantum
object is one whose observable
behavior reflects that
nature only offers
energy in discrete packets.
Now onto the next question.
What differentiates
quantum computing hardware
from a regular computer?
In essence, quantum
hardware lives
in a richer world than its
conventional counterpart.
Let's consider a simple,
abstract, quantum object,
which is entirely
described by the fact
that it can be in one of
two different energy levels.
Let's call those levels 0 and 1.
You can interpret those
brackets around the 0
to mean this is a quantum
energy level called "0."
And likewise for the "1."
Here, for example is a quantum
energy state named "psi."
Recall the classical bit of
information, a switch that
can take one of two values--
0 and 1.
Because of the apparent
similarity between our quantum
object and that classical
bit of information,
we call this quantum analog
a quantum bit, or qubit.
One peculiar feature
about quantum mechanics
is the existence
of superpositions.
A superposition is
like a special mixture
of the energy levels 0 and 1,
where the weight of each energy
level is given by complex
constants C0 and C1.
If we measure the
energy of our qubit,
we will sometimes observe
0, and sometimes 1,
where the value of sometimes
is given by the constants.
An individual measurement will
yield an outcome of 0 or 1.
There are no other options.
But before the
measurement occurs,
we know at most the chances
of getting a 0 or a 1.
We can't know the actual outcome
for sure until we measure it.
Therefore, when we want
to talk about the energy
state of the qubit before
we've made the measurement,
we use this superposition to
represent that the qubit hasn't
decided yet which
outcome to display,
even though the chances of
getting each outcome are fixed.
Now, even admitting that
this superposition business
is a little unusual.
We can accept that it's easy
enough to represent one qubit.
We just wrote it
down right there.
Thinking about more qubits
gets increasingly difficult.
Suppose we add a second qubit.
If these were
conventional switches,
we could think about each
switch independently.
But qubits are different.
Just as one qubit can be
in a superposition state,
two qubits can share
a superposition state,
where, for instance,
the measurement outcome
is unknown, but will certainly
be the same for both objects--
or opposite for both objects.
For example, here's
a state where
a blue qubit and a
yellow qubit are together
in a superposition state.
Here, they're correlated
to each other.
Before the measurement,
it cannot be known whether
the blue qubit will
turn up 0 or 1.
But a measurement of both qubits
will certainly always give
the same answer for each.
Similarly, in this case,
measuring the blue and yellow
qubits will always
give opposite outcomes.
This means that in order to
fully describe two qubits,
we need to consider C's for all
possible measurement outcomes
we could see.
To describe three qubits,
we need eight C's.
Describing four qubits
takes 16 C's, and so on.
Each time we add
another qubit, it
takes twice as much
information to describe
the whole pile of them.
That is the crux of
what differentiates
quantum hardware.
The quantum system
lives in a richer space,
so that representing n qubits
with a classical computer
requires 2 to the n numbers.
But does this mean that a
quantum memory with 100 qubits
corresponds to a
conventional memory with 2
to the 100th bits?
Not so fast.
Quantum hardware is very
effective at encoding
and processing certain
kinds of information.
But it cannot efficiently mimic
many useful aspects of its
classical counterpart.
When we say that a picture
is worth 1,000 words,
we don't abolish words
entirely in favor of pictures.
Adding quantum hardware to our
modern computing capabilities
would be like adding pictures to
a communication strategy that,
up to now, used only words.
So what does quantum
hardware do well?
The exponentially growing
complexity of quantum systems
also gives a clue about
where quantum hardware could
be useful.
In the fields of chemistry
and materials development,
simulation of molecules
could be a powerful technique
to learn about the
properties of a new molecule
before fully synthesizing
it in the lab.
However, our ability to
simulate chemistry on computers
is limited.
At its heart, chemistry
is an application
of quantum mechanics.
And each electron
we add to a model
doubles the number of
parameters, crippling computers
with expensive
calculations already
for very small molecules.
Suppose instead that we could
build chemistry models out
of a quantum Lego set.
Then the model would be built
with the same physics that
governs the system
being modeled.
In fact, chemistry and
materials simulations
have appeared as an
appealing near-term problem
to approach using
quantum hardware.
We've finally reached
the last question.
What does a quantum
computer look like,
and how do we build it?
Let's take a quick look
at the actual hardware
we're building at Google.
Our qubits are resonant
electrical circuits
made of patterned
aluminum on a silicon chip
that slosh electrical
current back and forth at two
different energy levels to
encode the quantum 0 and 1
states.
Here's an example of one
of our quantum chips.
Each chip features 72 qubits.
As you can see, it's about
the size of a quarter.
We want each qubit to behave
as one single quantum object,
with two levels.
Any other particle
interacting with a qubit
from its environment pulls it
away from this two-level ideal.
So creating a clean
qubit environment
is a critical challenge.
At the same time, we want
to be able to control
the qubits efficiently, adding
and removing quanta of energy
and letting pairs
of qubits interact
to exchange energy with
each other on demand.
These requirements seem
to oppose each other.
Ideal qubits should be perfectly
clean to interact with nothing.
But then in specific
cases, we want
them to interact very strongly.
This gives one insight into
the tensions and challenges
of building good
quantum hardware.
A first step toward
building clean qubits
is to build the
qubit circuits out
of superconducting
materials, which
experience no electrical loss.
Superconductors perform only
at very low temperatures.
And we operate our
qubits in a cryostat
at less than 50
millikelvin, just
a fraction of a degree
above absolute zero.
The cold temperatures and
vacuum inside a cryostat
also contribute to keeping
the qubit environment clean.
The cryostat
consists of a series
of nested plates and cans.
The warmest stage is at
the top, and it gets colder
as you go down.
All the equipment in the
central core of the cryostat
is responsible for
getting things cold.
Our hardware is installed
around the edges
and on the bottom,
coldest plate.
Each qubit chip must be
mounted in a package, which
holds the chip at millikelvin
temperatures and bridges
the gap between big
cables and a small chip.
To address the packaged
chip, electronics
outside the cryostat
send signals
through cables in the cryostat.
Each cable must carry electrical
signals from room temperature
all the way down to
the coldest stage,
while leaking only the
smallest amount of heat.
A large heat load would
prevent the cryostat
from reaching its
millikelvin base temperature.
A collection of
filters and amplifiers
outfits each cable
for its specific task.
The electronics
outside the cryostat
are controlled by code
running on a computer.
They generate precisely
calibrated electrical signals,
shaped pulses of
microwave radiation, which
are sent to control and
read out the qubits.
This entire system-- from chip
to cryostat, cables to code--
is all necessary to run
our quantum hardware.
I hope you have enjoyed digging
into some quantum computing
basics with me in
these last few minutes.
We talked about the
meaning of the word
"quantum," in particular, as it
relates to computer hardware.
Considering the idea of a
single qubit in superposition,
and then adding more qubits,
we saw that each time we
add another qubit, it takes
twice as much information
to describe the
whole pile of them.
That's what really
distinguishes a quantum computer
from a regular one.
Finally, I hope you
enjoyed the quick lab tour
to get a basic sense of what
our quantum computer looks like,
and what technology
we're developing in order
to build it.
Hopefully, the words
"quantum computer"
now have just a little
more meaning to you
than they did five minutes ago.
For more detailed information
about how we make and program
are quantum processors,
I invite you
to have a look at the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]